mais au moins on pourra justifier votre
geste par rapport à tout ce que vous
avez mis en place avant être une femme
seule dans la rue ou dans les transports
en commun n'est pas centraka c'est
pourquoi la ville de Triel-sur-Seine
organise chaque mois des cours
d'autodéfense pour les femmes j'étais
étudiante sur Paris avant et c'est vrai
que je me suis fait agresser de
nombreuses fois dans les transports et
et sur Paris et c'est vrai que je
j'avais besoin de de connaître les
moyens de défense en fait au cas où ça
se reproduise on se sent pas à l'aise
dans la rue Antoine dans notamment dans
le train dans le métro dans le RER c'est
souvent
pour nous à risquer enfin je trouve
au niveau des yeux ça va faire lâcher la
structure maintenant au bassin il est
comment
donc là le coup de genou
ces gestes ne sont pas anodins et
pourtant il pourrait sauver des vies
Pascal se formateur en self-défense
insiste sur l'attitude et les bons
gestes pour se défendre en cas de danger
on s'adresse à des femmes ou des mères
de famille qui n'ont pas forcément du
temps à consacrer à aller en club dans
une association apprendre des gestes
compliqués qui demandent x répétition là
on fait appel à souvent à l'inné
fonction des gestes très très simple
pour neutraliser une personne
temporairement sur des zones qu'on
appelle entre guillemets molle qui vont
fonctionner sur tout type de gabarit en
fait certaines d'entre elles assistent
au cours de manière régulière un moyen
rassurant et efficace non c'est très
simple et en fait on se rend compte que
on peut se défendre de tout nos propres
moyens et après il suffit de d'avoir les
gestes principales on a appris à se
défendre quand on est prise par
l'arrière l'avant
[Musique]
avec un sac à main en 2022 près de 300
femmes ont assisté au cours de celles
défenses thématiques du prochain
rendez-vous se défendre avec des objets
du quotidien